are we doing now welcome back to double
rapist to Scotland named Adam Graham has
sent a women's prison last week after
transitioning into a woman named Isla
Bryson beginning of his trial rapist has
now been moved and the Scottish
government's politically announced oh
this guy from violent trans inmates to
women's prisons the Scottish first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon is still
struggling with this issue take a look
at this are all trans women women they
haven't answered that question well
that's not the point that we're dealing
with yeah trans women are women but in
the present context there is no
automatic right for a trans woman there
are context where a trans woman is not a
woman no that is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate
born as a woman will be housed in the
real estate look we're talking here
about trans women I'm now asking about
women born as women I don't think that
our circumstances there uh but what's
different for trans women you've seen
this you've seen this joke I've seen
this story before about this is a rapist
who is a convicted rapist and a malecon
obviously and then he decided to become
a woman and now is being transferred to
a woman's prison so this is a man who
raped women now being transferred to
live among female prisoners and this is
the world we're we're living in I'm sure
that's going to end well they all they
have penises yes they have penises there
are there are multiple uh documented
cases of female prisoners being
impregnated by other trans women by
other female prisoners that is and this
is ridiculous this is just ridiculous
maybe we just have One National One
National prison for trans women who are
men dressed like women for the record
and and have them all go into one prison
we just build one just for them and then
they can all go in there and and talk
about hair and makeup sounds good with
me that is a risk assessment process
done for trans women
and part of their reasoning for wanting
to be in women's spaces used to they
used to run around and say because as
trans men we don't feel safe yeah they
said that for a while and they stopped
saying that because people were like oh
so you don't feel safe being in a room
full of men but you want to bring
yourself a man into a room full of woman
and disregard how the women feel yeah so
they don't say that one anymore so they
graduated from I no I just actually am a
woman excuse me they graduated too well
I'm just an actual woman and if you
don't believe I'm an actual woman then
you don't believe in the Easter Bunny or
Santa Claus either and you're a horrible
person yeah that's that's crazy to me
that like this isn't just you know
Social Media stuff like a dude actually
went to women's prison that is pretty
hard a lot of dudes are in women's
prisons right now I have a question
though what do you think about a trans
man so that's a woman who thinks she's a
man are they putting them into men's
prisons and because I haven't heard that
would not end well they would get raped
up the Wazoo right but but if you truly
if if I am to believe that that is
really a man why aren't they fighting
why aren't they fighting to get into
men's prisons are they not they're not I
haven't heard anything about that I
mostly hear about the men going into
women's prisons because it is an actual
threat to women yeah I mean yeah like
the the girl going into Men's prison
like they're putting themselves in that
situation like I'm just being honest so
it's like you're going there like what
[__] what do you think is gonna
happen you're with a bunch of prisoners
and you're a girl you're the only girl
like no [__] I think that's why it's not
either not happening or it's not being
discussed because the men are raping
each other in there like men are raping
men let alone if there's a girl with the
whole yeah yeah this is what happens
when when the woke mindset runs right
this is where it leads into complete and
utter Insanity that can't be explained
even by the people spewing it well
Jordan today's pack talk TV contributor
Esther Krakow and broadcaster Jenny
Cleveland I'm glad to be joined by daily
wire columnist The Man Behind The
Smashing what's going on he's a woman
Matt Walsh Matt walls uh I mean every
time I think this can't get more absurd
this simple question in terms of a
response from them oh [__] this thing is
massive right now
we get something like that we're a
leader of the country Nicola sturgeon
the leader of Scotland simply incapable
of explaining why if trans women are
women then they have to be kept in male
prisons
yeah I mean if there weren't such frauds
and cowards you'd almost feel sorry for
them they backed themselves into this
corner and they're left they're left
with as you said absolute gibberish uh
because that's the that's the
fundamental incoherence at the bottom of
gender Theory it's totally incoherent
and all you have to do is ask some basic
questions and that's revealed and by the
way this idea of well we'll do a risk
assessment well look if it was a if
there are female prisoners uh even very
danger if there's an actual female
prisoner who was larger and stronger
you'd have to do a risk assessment there
but there'd be no thought about whether
that prisoner goes to a woman's prison
or not right obviously that prisoner's
gonna be a women's prison right so I
mean I think you know in a way this this
case has really exposed this whole issue
actually in the most sharpest possible
way because even this rapist ex-wife
came out and said he never mentioned any
of this stuff when they were married for
eight years and she thinks he's invented
the whole transitioning simply to get
himself a cushier a place in a woman's
prison well
he's just a meme it's just a meme the
whole thing is just a meme have you seen
like the the South Park thing where
Cartman is a woman the one where he goes
to the gynecologist and complains no no
no no a different one word Cartman's a
woman well you can watch that next make
sure you watch that video which is what
he's done before which is why is it
convicted rapist
and I say he because I just don't
believe that he's a genuine transitioner
at all I think he just scammed at
everybody including the legal system
yeah I think he is right and by the way
even if he was a quote genuine
transition right still call him here
because uh he means man that's what he
is no matter how he feels about himself
I do think it exposes something because
at the heart of this debate whether
we're talking about locker rooms or
sports teams or prisons it's always a
question of first of all what is a
quote-unquote trans woman how do you
define it but then also you have these
competing claims you have the you have
the uh the the the the quote-unquote
trans person who says that well if you
don't do as I say it's going to make me
feel bad about myself then you have all
the other people who are affected who
say well if you let them do what they
want then we are going to be unsafe and
when you when you translate this over to
a prison and you're talking about
putting violent predators and sex
offenders in with with with women
because if you don't the the violent
Predator will feel bad yeah I was like
okay this is my logic we're worried
about the violent Predators feelings as
we should over safety this is ridiculous
this is not lasting this is a fad and
this is going to go away because sanity
is Rule it is making a comeback I can
see it everywhere I go people are
opening their mouths they have had it
this is [__] and as a woman who will
hopefully never be in jail one day but
it is not just the prisons again it's
the dressing rooms the locker rooms the
bathrooms that they want men in as a
woman I will say we are waking up and
realizing that this monster that they
created I'm glad you're waking control
it's like Frankenstein I've been on that
wave you know I'm saying no I mean
collectively I have obviously been awake
to this for a long time that I don't
want men
um about how does one get this it's got
to be a while back it's got to be five
or six years at least I was in Cambridge
Massachusetts at the um art it's a
theater run by Harvard and it is a
fantastic theater they produce really
the AR the American Repertory Theater
and they produce fantastic content the
stuff I've seen there and I went with a
friend and I went we went at
intermission to the the bathrooms and
and they were unisex where is this in
Harvard Square at Harvard and there's
dudes in the theater and there were it
was unisex and there were men and women
and you know waiting for the Stalls
because I had to go I had no choice I
hated it and then I do what I have to do
I come out I'm washing my hands and I'm
a woman and I'm dressed up because I'm
out for a night and I want to just touch
up my lipstick and I'm like I'm doing
this with guys around this is
uncomfortable it was uncomfortable it
was uncomfortable and I came out and I
said to my friend I hated that and she
was and she was far more liberal than me
and she was like well you know it's
inclusive for everybody and I was just
like what about the woman who has been
sexually assaulted and it just is
uncomfortable in that in pulling her
pants down in a room with men what about
her to hell with her all of a sudden so
that's some lunatic with gender
dysphoria can feel good about themselves
no sorry it's funny because like they
[__] on men they hate men but then now
it's like in that scenario they care
about men's feelings it's just proof
that they only care about what they're
totally care about you're absolutely
right because men are bad men are pigs
men men should be kept away from women
and gyms and things because they can't
be trusted because they're violent and
aggressive yet yes let's go in the
bathroom and and take our pants off and
with them between a paper-thin wall with
them right there or looking through a
crack yeah okay it was terrible it was a
bad experience and it far overshadowed
the play that I saw I'll never forget it
and now things are far worse in the Work
World then you have all the other people
who are affected who say well if you let
them do what they want then we are going
to be unsafe and when you when you
translate this over to a prison and
you're talking about putting violent
predators and sex offenders in with but
they're not women because if you don't
the the violent Predator will feel bad I
was like okay well we can it's bad it's
mad
it's a tax evading man who now decides
to be a woman that's okay still not over
well you have six foot three inch
swimmers pulverizing women born to
female bodies in the pool and breaking
all women's records potentially
irrevocably Jenny can you defend any of
this I mean I think it's a really
Stark example of where this begins to
fall down or binary and sex is binary
gender is not binary gender is a is a
Continuum but but sex is binary and why
why when did this become a thing too
like sex and gender aren't the same
thing like this is they're just making
[__] up at this point this is a hall of
fantasy language
um we've talked about the little kids
who now they're they're animals and you
get to be you decide you want to pretend
to be a bird and then everyone has to
act like you are a real Bird gender is a
is a Continuum but but sex is binary and
whilst there is a kind of drive to be
inclusive and to be welcoming it gets to
a certain point where when you're
conflating gender and sex when you have
a situation where it's either a male
prison or a female prison that's where
this all throws out I'm not going to try
and defend you agree with me blimey I
Know It Feels Right returning the wokies
in real time here my my point with the
Trans people like they make that [__]
their identity like they're not even a
person anymore like when you're trying
friends like that's all they talk about
like they put like trans and proud in
their bio and they're like every piece
of content that they post is about their
transition and it's like is that it is
that is that the extent of you you're
just trying yes you know what I'm saying
yes they have taken they have taken on
the part of their their sexuality as the
prime
um their Prime characteristic in their
life but also they they'll defend it
because they'll say that they're doing
that as part of a cause to make other
people feel empowered and brave maybe if
you just like did it and didn't shove it
down everyone's throat and you just were
like a human then it wouldn't be as big
of a deal you know what I mean like you
just all right I'm a girl but like you
didn't talk about it all the time like
you just did your normal human [__] yeah
if anybody talks about it it's like
anything it's the same thing with gay
people like some gay people the make
that their personality and like I know
gay people that don't like the gay
people that do that and then there's
some gay people who are just like people
and they're gay and it's like nobody
cares nobody cares I just think it's a
lot of it about being a bad personality
right so forget all this gay stuff like
if somebody comes over and all they talk
about is work you go to dinner with them
and then you see them a week later for
drinks and you see them another time for
coffee and all they're like and then at
work and then at work and then at work
and then at work and you're like after a
while like do you have anything else to
talk about can you talk about a book you
read or politics or news or your family
the political economic state of the
world anything so when somebody just
Harps and harps and harps and harps on
the same thing they're dull and
uninteresting and that's what these
people are and they're crazy and I think
maybe a lot of them are on the spectrum
because they're they're completely
unaware of how they make what they're
doing feel you know how they make other
people feel in social situations that is
I think the way you try and introduce
you know Limitless self-identity of any
kind yeah this is where it goes right it
goes to insane places which are actually
dangerous this is dangerous but it's
also State overreach and I feel like no
one's pointed this out because the the
state is not in the business of I'm
sorry accommodating the the the needs of
trans identifying prisoners that's not
their business right you can feel how
you want like you said prisons are
binary and they're binary for a reason I
went to a gym this afternoon I was in
the female gym showers I can't imagine a
person born with a penis I.E a male
being in there it's horrifying so I I
think even the fact that you know people
feel like it's the government's business
to accommodate trans prison this is
completely proposed the thing that I
would like to know is I would like to
know where trans men go to prison
nobody's talking about that because
trans men is women
no one talks about trans men and women
do we talk about trans men in men's
sports do we talk about
so you acknowledge that the girls
wouldn't qualify in the boy sports but
the boys can play in the women's sports
but it doesn't matter there I'm talking
about real real boys and girls or trans
boys and girls I know what I'm saying
I'm telling about what they really are
one way thank you right biologically in
a swimming pool or sprinting or whatever
it may be people born to male bodies
have an advantage over female bodies
predominantly almost exclusively right
we separated the Sexes at the Olympics
there's no Advantage with it
yes there is and that would has she ever
heard of prison violence what does she
think the prison is the Magic Gardens
you even know what imagine Garden is it
was the 70s TV show everything was
lovely there she thinks this is the Mad
prison is the magic garden it's not it's
a horrible violent place even low even
minimum security prisons have violence
in
I have not been to prison as a prisoner
but yes I have been to prison oh like to
visit prison yes yeah yeah
kind of really shed light on all of this
issues well you mentioned Jim's uh
Esther when we come back and talk to to
Matt and then you guys about this new
extraordinary viral digital craze of
women shaming men for looking at them in
the gym all right well that was it as
usual you know these people make no
sense but I hate that joke it's so it's
so such a mean
okay it's not
I think that it's funny because I think
I've said that around someone else your
age and they got mad and um because it's
because it's something that an [__]
says it's not even a funny like I know
but I'm saying like like every like it's
just like a common thing to say when
like a gen Z just like a common among
people who have no regard for other
people that it's a common thing among
people who aren't nice people and maybe
you need to change your Society if
that's who you're hanging out with
people that say things like that and
that's become part of your everyday
vernacular I'll cut it out I'm sorry
parenting man you guys know what I mean
whatever all right thank you so much for
watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram and I'll see you
later
[Music]
gone